I think people are going to Rally around
president Trump we know that our
elections are corrupt here they've been
corrupt for a long time 2020. we saw
what happened when we ignored a corrupt
election and allowed someone like Joe
Biden to get into the White House and
Lead our country into destruction and I
just make you can you can look down the
camera and say that but you know that's
not true you know that the election was
not stoked I wouldn't expect you coming
from Australia to know one day you're
from the UK country oh you're from the
UK I was told you're from Australia okay
so you'd speak to someone who is on the
right of politics but not not to an
independent gender expect you to
understand what's happening in our
country because I can see you come at
this from a left agenda which is very
typical of the fake news and the people
are listening to you they really aren't
and you don't understand what it means
to shed blood for your freedom like we
did here when we broke ourselves free
from a tyrant called King George so when
you learn a little bit about our history
then I'll have a conversation but you
don't know what the hell you're talking
about oh